he's got a question why did Jesus say my
God my God why have you forsaken me so
the question is it's twofold why did he
call the father my God and why did he
say the father forsook him okay so we're
going to answer those questions so if
you're ready let's answer the first one
why would Jesus call the father his God
so now do you want to read the Bible for
me you got your Bible I have the verses
in front of me but no I'm saying you you
have a Bible with you or a Bible app or
something yeah I have the Bible left
okay get it open what version of the
Bible do you
read um King James or new king change
all right whatever is going to be easy
for you to understand use that okay all
right because I want you to understand
uh so if the Cano King James is easier
use that for now because you said you
were born you're French Canadian so I'm
assuming French is your mother Kong yes
all right so if the new King James I can
I can read in English no problem
but if the new King James is easier then
follow that now the first question okay
first go to Jeremiah
32:27 and you know what's ironic about
your
question because the answer to the first
question will lead into the answer to
the second question because it goes back
to Psalm 22 now in Jeremiah 32:27 read
for me what it says about God the true
God oh just give me a second sure do I'm
trying to find the Jeremiah yeah
Jeremiah 32:27 just get your app ready
and have it just you know find is is
Jeremiah in the old test of course my
friend it's actually in the
vadas I'm Kidd okay Jeremiah
okay okay so I start reading if you want
to if you don't read we're going to be
here all day okay behold I am Jehovah
the God of All Flesh is there anything
too hard for me okay read it one more
time read it one more time
distraction behold I am Jehovah the God
of All Flesh is there anything too hard
for me okay so Jehovah is the God of All
Flesh
right yes okay now here's my question
for you if God is a trinity Father Son
and Holy Spirit Jesus the word becomes
flesh he becomes a human being he
becomes flesh not the father not the
spirit and Jesus becomes flesh in order
to serve the father on Earth should it
surprise you that when Jesus becomes
flesh the father becomes his
God okay should it surprise you yes or
no no because Jesus is not just God he's
also Jesus was okay sorry no go
ahead since since Jesus was onhe so he
was 100% man man and he's still 100% man
in Heaven he didn't stop becoming man
because after the resurrection Jesus was
raised in his physical body he's still a
man in heaven and he'll be a man forever
what I'm saying is when he did come to
the earth and the Holy Spirit conceived
the physical body the human nature of
the word from the Blessed womb of the
Virgin Mary when he was conceived to
become a
human being from that moment on should
it surprise you the father becomes his
God
no Mak sense now let me prove it to you
John 1 verse one go to John chapter 1
verse
one give
me okay okay now read what does it say
in
john11 in the beginning was the word and
the Word was with God and the Word was
God so notice same was in no you're
going to verse two just one brother just
follow with me it's okay so in John 1:1
let's unpack John 1:1 there it says in
the beginning was the word the word was
with God there it means he's with God
the father and the Word was God meaning
the word had the nature of God so what
the father is the word is because the
word belongs to the father and shares in
his nature right right okay but then
notice verse 14 though what did the word
do verse 14 and the word became flesh
and dwelt Among Us and beheld His glory
glory as of the only begotten from the
father full of grace and truth okay
remember that Jehovah said am I not the
God of All Flesh right cor right yeah so
did the word become
flesh yes it did and when the word
became flesh he because it's a person
it's a Divine person he became flesh he
did so to serve his father and fulfill
his father's will right right so if he
came to serve his father by becoming
flesh on Earth then the father father
becomes as
God yeah okay now let me prove but let
me prove to you that Jesus only had a
God over him from the moment he became
human I'm going to prove that to you and
this will lead to why Jesus said my God
my God why have you forsaken me go to
Psalm 22 verse1 you're going to see
where Jesus was quoting
from okay go to Psalm 22 verse1
when you get there you can
read my God my God why has do forsaken
me why is that for you're reading the
King James again yeah okay so do me a
favor switch to the new King James
because you said do it's why hast Thou
forsaken me but go to the new King James
if you can okay change it to the new
King James my God my God why have you
forsaken me so you see where Jesus is
going
from yeah but finish the verse from from
the you finish the verse fulfilling the
prophecy yeah but you didn't finish the
verse finish
it okay why are you so far from helping
me and from the words of my groaning I I
don't know what groaning means means but
groaning meaning My Cry my pain my cry
to you okay
okay okay so read it
again my God my God why have you
forsaken me why are you so far from
helping me and from the words of my
groaning so this Psalm Jesus quotes my
God my God why have you forsaken me now
to further proof it's about Jesus read
Psalm
22:16 Psalm
22:16 for dogs have surrounded me the
con Congregation of the wicked has
enclosed
me you pierced my hands and my what does
that sound like I can only count my
bones okay so Psalm 22:6 one more
time for dogs have surrounded me of the
wicked go has enclosed me they pierced
my hands and my feet okay so that sounds
like Jesus being nailed to the cross
right yeah okay so they have pierced my
hands and my feet okay good to further
prove it's about Jesus read Psalm
22:18 they divide my garment among them
and for my clothing they cast
lots read it one more time so it sinks
in and
focus they divide my garments among them
and for my clothing they cast lots now
did this happen to Jesus when he was
nailed to the cross now go to John
19 John
19 23- 24
watch
here 23 to
24 then the soldiers when they had
crucified Jesus took his garments and
made four parts to each Soldier aart and
also the tunic now the tunic was without
seam moving from the top in one piece
they said therefore among themselves let
us not tear it but cast lots for it who
who it shall be that the scripture might
be fulfilled which says they divided my
garments among them and for my clothing
they cast lots therefore the soldier did
these things okay so did Jesus fulfill
Psalm 2218 where they would cast lots
for his garments and divide his
clothing yes okay so he fulfilled it
right so Psalm 22 is fulfilled in Jesus
right yeah okay now now go to Psalm
22:10 to prove Psalm 22:10 will prove
that the father only became Jesus's God
when Jesus became human when he was
conceived in the Blessed womb of his
mother to be a human being Psalm
22:10 I was cast upon your I was cast
upon you from birth from my mother's
womb you have been my God how long have
you been my God since when from the
mother's womb so before he entered his
mother's womb did he have a God over
him no so Jesus only had a God over him
in his mother's womb when the Virgin
Mary conceived by the parly spirit the
human nature the physical body of Jesus
so when Jesus becomes human that's when
God the father becomes his God when
Jesus becomes human side note by the way
for everyone for you and all the
Brethren notice this shows that a human
being is a human life at conception at
conception in the womb God already
recognizes you as a human being which is
why abortion is murder we condemn it as
murder and
satanic
right right because from my mother's
womb I'm a human being a human life with
human dignity human value and you've
been my
God
right right so did that answer the first
question why could G why would Jesus
have a God over
him yeah because he was a he was a he he
became flesh and as soon as he was in in
his mother's womb because he's human he
had a God over him he was human yeah all
right now to further prove it's about
Jesus I'm G to so you have no doubt it's
about Jesus in Psalm 22 Psalm
22 verse 4 to8 read that for
me 48
yeah our father trusted in you they
trusted and you delivered them they
cried to you and were delivered trusted
in you louder so we can hear our father
father trusted in you they trusted and
you delivered them they cried to you and
were delivered they trusted in you and
were not ashamed but I am a worm and no
man man a re a reproach of a man and
despised by the people all those who see
me ridicul me they Sho out the lip they
shake the head saying he trusted in the
Lord let him rescue him let him deliver
him since he Delights in him notice the
reaction of the people when he when they
see him they shake their like saying
look at this guy and then they mock him
he trusts in the Lord let God rescue him
let him deliver him since he trusts in
him
right right okay now let's see what they
said to Jesus when he was on the cross
go to Matthew 27 I want you to read
37-44 Matthew 27 37- 44 I'm going to
answer the second part of your question
Matthew 27
37-44 Matthew
27 37 to 44 yep 37 to 44 yes and make
sure you're loud so we can all hear yeah
okay
so and they put up over his head the
accusations WR the accusation written
against him this is Jesus the king of
the Jews then two robbers were crucified
with him one on the right and another on
the left and those who passed by the
blasphemed
him waging their W wagging their heads
and saying you who destroyed the temple
and build it in three days save yourself
if you are the Son of God come down from
the cross likewise the chief priests
also mocking with the scribes and Elders
said he saved others himself he cannot
save if he is the king of Israel let him
now come down from the cross and we will
believe him he trusted in God let him
deliver him now if he will have him for
he said I am the Son of God doesn't that
sound like Psalm 2 see again before you
read 44 doesn't that sound before you
read 44 doesn't it sound like Psalm 2278
they waged their heads they shook his
head and they say let the Lord deliver
him because he says he trusts in
him yeah and doesn't that sound exactly
what they said to Jesus on the cross
they shook their heads they wagged their
heads at him saying let God deliver him
for he said he is God's
son Yes sounds the same
right yeah it's the same now read 44 you
didn't I stopped you read now Matthew
27:44 to finish
it yeah even the robbers who were
crucified with him reviled him with the
same thing so they're all mocking him
now why then did Jesus say my God my God
why have you forsaken me the answer
comes from that same Psalm Psalm 22 and
I want champed white to now
hear the proper interpretation now
before I show you why first you need to
read Matthew 27 read 45
slowly that's 45 slowly yes because I
want you to catch the con
now for the sixth hour until the ninth
hour there was Darkness over all the
land now pay attention to that the
darkness lasted from the sixth hour
which was 12 noon according to Jewish
time to the 9th hour 3M so my question
listen to my question why then did the
darkness end at the ninth hour why did
it end at the ninth hour now you know
what your answer
is what Matthew 26 7
46 2726 46 46 46 and about the ninth
hour Jesus cried out with a loud voice
saying Ellie
Lama yeah that is my God my God why have
you forsaken me so do you see why the
darkness ended at 9th hour because
that's when Jesus said those words and
when he said those words the darkness
ended okay it's Jesus's words that
removed the darkness from the
land he cried my God my God why have you
forsaken at 9th hour after that the
darkness
ended okay did you catch that first
because I'm G explain why but are you
catching it why did it last till the
n9th hour because Jesus prayed at the
ninth hour and after he prayed the
darkness is
removed yeah okay you got it now yeah
okay now why because the words my God my
God why have you forsaken me isn't like
oh why did you abandon no no no now
let's go to back go back to Psalm 22:1
to see what those words mean because
he's quoting Psalm 22
verse1 one more time so you can see the
connection my God my God why have you
forsaken me why are you so far from help
me and from the little louder that part
you broke up so you see you're scaring
me read that part again why are you
why are you so far why are you so far
from helping me and from the words of my
groaning so it's not why you forsaken me
it's a prayer saying how much longer
must I wait for you to deliver me that's
Jesus's Point okay father I've now drank
the cup of judgment I paid the price how
much more longer will I be under
judgment and you'll rescue me in other
words it's accomplished salvation has
been has been wrought salvation has been
accomplished now time for the darkness
to end so it's a prayer to the father
now ends the judgment and God answers
yes son it's over you've been answered
I've come to your
rescue okay so it was basically the last
uh prophecy that had to be fulfilled
and and it's a prophecy not that God is
abandoning him but that okay when now
will you come to my rescue and my
Deliverance because that's Psalm 221
right my God my God why have you
forsaken me why are you so far from
helping me and then when he says that
notice what Psalm 22 23 to 24 says Psalm
22 23- 24 says look what it
says says um I will declare your name to
my brethren in the midst of the assembly
I will praise you you who fear the Lord
Praise You all you descendants of Jacob
glorify him and fear Him all of you
offsprings offsprings of Israel for he
has not despised nor abhor the a
Affliction of The Afflicted nor has he
hidden his face from him but when he
cried to him he he heard ah do you catch
it Rejoice with me because when I cried
out to him he heard me and delivered me
that's why the darkness ended the
darkness ending at his prayer was a sign
son I've heard you now I come to deliver
you the judgment is over time for you to
come
home nice okay you got it now yeah I got
it makes sense yeah it makes sense
thanks thanks thanks a lot no thank the
Lord for that that was that just to show
you so you understand it's not oh while
you for it's okay now that the price has
been paid I've accomplished
salvation how long will you delay in
coming to my Deliverance now that the
price has been paid and the answer it's
not asking he doesn't know it's it's a
prayer in the sense now time for me to
come home time for me to be delivered
because judgment is over and the answer
that God answered him and said amen he
removed the darkness right when he
prayed yes son it's over time for me to
come and deliver you and bring you home
that's why right after that then he says
father into your hands I commit my
spirit you see
yeah makes sense so that's why when
people keep telling me Psalm 22 what
does that mean
exactly what does that mean okay explain
why is he quoting Psalm 22 what's the
relevance of quoting Psalm 22 how does
that prove anything see people just they
just parot what they hear but they don't
understand